[MUSIC PLAYING]
So I think a lot about this
relationship between beauty,
aesthetic works, and catharsis.
And at what price?
The philosopher Alain De
Botton had an amazing passage
in his book, "The
Architecture of Happiness"
in which he described an
individual being so moved
by work of art that he
was shaken to tears.
He was literally bawling
because he was so
affected by the outrageous
beauty emanating from the work
that he was looking at.
And the imaginary
foundation define beauty
as this kind of rousing,
symphonic climax.
It's explosive.
So this extraordinary
moment of poetry and grace.
But, again, at what price?
And I recently came across
an actual affliction
called the Stendhal Syndrome.
This is an actual
psychosomatic condition.
And actual medical
condition in which
an individual can be so moved
by an aesthetic work, a work
of art can affect him so
deeply that he can, literally,
lose consciousness.
The individual can,
literally, pass out
from the aesthetic impact
of the work of art.
How far are we willing to
go to make beautiful art?
Can beautiful art destroy us?
The artist has to ask himself
this question all the time.
At what price?
Can you have too much ecstasy?
How far are we willing to go
to have that catharsis, even
if it kills us?
Can we be destroyed by
art, by our own art?
I guess that's the question.
[MUSIC PLAYING}